as for spacecraft so this is
we're nearing the end of our spacecraft
question then we'll get to the physics
okay
great so as for the ufo spacecraft do
you
imagine that they're taking advantage of
some new physics and when i say new
physics what i mean is
physics that we don't understand so
maybe like lazar is correct with a
strong force being a gravitational one
or maybe there's a fifth force
or maybe they're utilizing your
partially ordered set manner of
constructing space time from the ground
up
or do you think it's just technological
sophistication in the same way that a
cell phone if
the cell phone isn't using any new
physics quote unquote
since the 1950s we pretty much could
understand how this operated it's just
the technical sophistication do you
imagine it's technical sophistication or
the utilization of new physics it's a
good question
i suspect that there is some new physics
and the reason
i think that is because we don't see
these things appear to be violating
conservation of momentum
so when the object takes off you know at
this huge acceleration
there gonna be something moving the
other way right um
and that we don't observe that so you
have that problem
the fact that they move through air
almost effortlessly with no sonic booms
um is a problem
the uh yeah so for instance that the tic
tac
object that was observed on radar to
drop from 28 thousand feet to sea level
in 0.78 seconds at the midpoint it had
to be going
about 35 000 miles an hour that's mach
60 right that's great and that and
that's as fast as the
new horizons probe that went to pluto
so that little that little tic tac
object basically as it dropped to sea
level
accelerated to the speed of the new
horizons probe
within um 0.4 seconds
which is really remarkable
and so it did that without a sonic boom
and
um and it's not clear how that's
possible so
it really does look like there's some
new physics involved
and then for people who then question
the
you know there's the question always
often comes up why do you
assume that these are ex these are
spacecraft
and the answer is really simple because
they travel at the speeds of spacecraft
that's
they travel at those speeds and they
travel
with accelerations that could would not
only make them
viable interstellar craft but it would
make them excellent
interstellar craft so